in terms of priorities
how much would you allocate
to trying to make contact with aliens
and getting their help
and if we look at the next 500 beyond
years
and just
versus option number two really just
focusing on setting up the party on our
own engineering
our on our own um
the genome the biology of humanity the
ai
collaborating with humans just all the
engineering challenges and opportunities
that we're um
we're exploring
i'm focused in my lab of course a lot on
the engineering of genomes the
monitoring of astronauts during long
missions
uh you know reaching out to other aliens
we've been doing reach out to aliens
since the first radio waves been
broadcast so we're doing some of it but
to do them really made it sound like
your lab is mostly focused on biology
but you also reach out occasionally
occasionally when they visit they have
they bring their whiskey you know we
have a drink but the
uh
i think we we can do we've been
broadcasting into space for you know at
this point almost a century getting
close to
and
you know so but it's not been structured
so i think it's very cheap and easy to
send out structured messages um like
what carl sagan wrote about in contact
doing prime numbers and sending those
out to indicate intelligence
uh so there's things we can do that i
think are very cheap and very easy so we
should do some of that we can walk and
chew gum at the same time this is one of
the biggest critiques people often say
of space research and even space flight
in general is too expensive shouldn't we
solve poverty shouldn't we cure diseases
and the answer is always as it always
has been is that you can walk and chew
gum at the same time you can
pass the civil rights act and go to the
moon in the same decade you can improve
um and and get rid of structural
inequality while getting to uh the moon
and mars in this decade so i think i
think we can do both
yeah they kind of help each other
there's sometimes criticism of like
ridiculous science like studying
penguins or something or studying the
patterns of birds or fish and so on some
congressman stands up and says this is a
waste of taxpayer dollars and then but
someone said but we and for example
crispr was pure research for 25 years
now it's a household word and students
are editing genomes in high school but
it was just pure research on weird
bacteria living actually in salt uh
hyper saline lakes and rivers for
decades and then eventually became a
massive therapeutic which is like a
curing of diseases in this past year and
there's stuff that you discover as part
of the research that you didn't
anticipate they have nothing to do with
the actual research like oceanography
is one of the interesting things about
that whole field
is that it's a huge amount of data and
neuroscience too actually so you could
discover
computer science
things like machine learning things or
even data storage manipulation
distributed compute things by having to
forcing yourself to get something done
about on the oceanography side that's
how you invent
the internet
and
and all those kinds of things so to me
aliens looking for aliens
out there in the universe
is
a motivator that just inspires inspires
everybody young people
old people scientists artists
um engineers entrepreneurs everybody
this somehow the that line between
fear and beauty
because we're aliens are like perfectly
merged basically
because this we don't know i mean for
you
let's start talking about primitive
alien life are you excited by it
or are you terrified
i want to make a lotion out of it i
think it'd be great if it's alien life
assuming it's safe but i'm very excited
uh it doesn't have to be you just said a
half sentence presuming it's safe that's
the fundamental question
so if you could yes presuming it's safe
so i think you know we have this uh this
beginning of some planetary protection
is happening now is we're gonna send
we're bringing rocks back from mars in
2033 volgos according to plan
but there's always a danger what if you
bring this back what if it's alive what
if it will kill all of humanity or
michael creighton wrote a book the
andromeda strain about this very idea
and we could but it hopefully won't and
the only way you can you know really
gauge that is the same way we do with
any infectious agent here on earth right
if it's a new pathogen a new organism
you do it slowly carefully you often do
it with levels of containment
so
you know and it's gonna be probably have
to be where some pioneers go and would
be for example on mars there might be
other organisms there that only get
activated once there's an ambient
temperature and more humidity then
suddenly the first settlers on mars are
encountering a strange new fungus or
something that's not even like a fungus
because it might be a different clade of
life a different branch of life
and could be very dangerous or it could
be very inert i mean most of life on
earth on earth is
not really
dangerous or harmful let me go back
hiked on this
most of life on earth is neither harmful
nor beneficial to you it's just they're
making its own way in the universe just
trying to survive it's when you know
it's inside of you and replicating your
cells and destroying yourselves like a
virus like like like covid xrcv2 that it
becomes a big problem of course but it's
you know just doesn't really have agency
it's just trying to get by and so for
example most of the bacteria on the
table on your skin
in the subway are pretty inert they're
just
you know people hanging around for the
ride and actually
just because we're talking so much trash
about viruses most viruses are
don't bother humans they're phages
almost all the vast majority of viruses
are phages there's this this the battle
in the biology that is really dorky is
that bacteria think that they're the
most you know people study bacteria
think the bacteria are the most
important because there's trillions and
trillions of them they run a lot of our
own biology in our body but then people
who study phages they say well there's
10 times more phages than the bacteria
which can attack the bacteria and
destroy them as well so
phage people think that they run the
world uh but
we need them both
uh what do you think about viruses all
right so because you you said alien
organisms wouldn't we encounter
something like bacteria something like
viruses
as the first alien life form are they
first of all are viruses alive
or not
so by the book definition if you pick up
a biology textbook they'd say
technically no because they don't have
the ability to self-replicate
independently
but i would think if you
restructure how you view what life is
it's just autonomously
aggregating and replicating of
information uh
for example ai at some point what if
there's an ai platform that we could
consider alive like at what point would
you allow it to say it's alive and i
think we have the same definitional
challenge there is that if it can
continually propagate instructions for
its own existence
then it is a version of living i think
you know viruses don't get that
category because
they can't do it on their own but they
are a version of life i'd say but
probably not alive
well
they are expressing themselves and doing
so on occasion quite powerfully in human
civilization so
um
like you said at which point
our ai systems allowed to say
we're life
we are allowed
humans
must allow them
and the viruses didn't ask for
permission to express themselves to
humans they just kind of they just kind
of did yeah we didn't have to allow them
are they overall though exciting or
terrifying to you as somebody who has
studied viruses well whenever given two
options there's always two more i could
do both or neither so here i'll say
they're both
terrifying and exciting i think to me
more exciting than terrifying i think if
i had to make that sandwich and how many
layers are you know meat versus cheese
there's a lot more cheese of excitement
and meat meat is
sandwich